thank you for joining us at five right
now metro police are investigating a
homicide on the east side of las vegas
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez police telling us
that it happened near
nellis and charleston boulevard that's
where we find madison kimbra who just
arrived on the scene madison
yeah so there is very heavy police
activity right now
you can take a look and pan off where
you're going to really see the extent of
what is going on
here is what we know so far we are
awaiting a briefing from police at any
moment
here's what we know just after two metro
police received a call of a shooting on
montello avenue
when police arrived they found a person
dead from a gunshot wound
no word on if there is a shooter in
custody yet again we are waiting for a
briefing on what happened and that's
going to happen in a matter of minutes
of course we will bring you the latest
online and on air
on facebook and on our website reporting
live madison kimbrough
8 news now